depuis hier vous le savez le rideau est
fermé sur les petits commerces de centre
ville et village dit non essentiels les
plus fragiles d'entre eux ne pensent pas
pouvoir survivre
un deuxième confinement ils crient à
l'injustice quand dans le même temps les
grandes surfaces restent ouvertes en
vendant dans certains rayons les mêmes
produits que fleurs à bille ou encore
services de cordonnerie à bourgueil
lucas chopin colère et inquiétude au
premier jour du confinement
les petits commerçants de bourgueil ne
se résignent pas ils réclament des
mesures plus justes pour pouvoir rester
ouverts certains craignent même de ne
pas tenir le choc va économiquement je
pense qu'on ne va pas pouvoir s'en
sortir on a déjà tout mis en branle pour
la preuve le premier confinement on a
tous d'étaler et je veux dire en fait
une entreprise c'est comme un ménage
quand vous avez un salaire vous pouvez
pas dépenser plus que ce que vous avez
on tolère que les grandes surfaces
restent ouvertes reçoivent un flux
d'individus qui sont potentiellement
transmetteur du virus a contrario on
ferme des boutiques comme la mienne qui
fait même pas 30 mètres carrés que je
souhaite c'est que l'état fasse quand
même un petit geste au niveau des petits
commerçants alentour éthique commune
parce que c'est vrai ça va devenir
compliqué quoi pour guillaume la pac
président de l'union commerciale et
artisanale de bourgueil l'état devrait
adapter les règles selon la démographie
des agglomérations
une personne par une personne dans nos
petites villes c'est tout à fait
possible ça nous empêcherait pas de
travailler nous ce qu'on demande la
seule chose qu'on demande c'est que les
règles soient bien adaptés en fonction
des densités de population il est clair
que la place plumereau c'est pas la même
chose que le cordonnier de bourgueil
hier les commerçants se sont entretenus
avec une députée dans l'espoir de faire
entendre leurs revendications